- Here at Pine Hill Middle,
we have a diverse group
- Raise your hand if you have
at least three lessons passed.
Good job.
- When it comes to Ms.
Grubbs, she is so creative.
One of the resources she has used
is Khan Academy with the LearnStorm.
- This class mainly focuses on students
with learning needs so we have
to come up with alternative strategies
to kind of try to help those students.
LearnStorm is an excellent
resource for differentiation.
Differentiation, it's one of the most
difficult things to accomplish.
They expect you to have one person
to service thirty people individually.
Is everybody ready?
- [Whole Class] Yes, ma'am.
- Alright, he got three over here.
I don't necessarily grade
accuracy, I grade progress.
So, LearnStorm is a good
way to differentiate
and as well as motivate and
with the growth mindset pieces
you can also educate them about
why it's important to learn,
how they learn, how their
body is set up to learn,
which strategies help them learn.
It's amazing, it's amazing and it's free.
It's free!
- The best part of doing LearnStorm,
it built up my confidence to do more.
To do better for myself.
Be a better person.
- I think one of the most
inspirational stories
was one of my students.
He was the first one to
complete all 60 assignments
and after he completed
those 60 assignments,
he asked for more.
- I did over 300 lessons in one week.
LearnStorm is good.
I felt proud of myself
getting all these good grades.
(upbeat music)
- End of each week, I assess my students.
Every single one of 'em
shows significant progress
and their energy improved significantly
because they believe they can do it now.
So, they're very, very, very happy
and pleased with themselves.
I would encourage any
teacher to utilize LearnStorm
as a motivational tool for
students to get started.
Kinda get that jump started
at the beginning of the year.
I mean, you want students to
get excited about learning.
What better way than the LearnStorm
to get them excited about learning.
- [Whole Class] LearnStorm,
LearnStorm, LearnStorm!